welcome back to you Rockstars it's me
Tommy B and today we are whipping up a
batch of Star Wars awesomeness a bad
batch to be specific that's right bad
batch season two has just begun over a
month ago I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I
know we're late but I was frozen in
carbonite because I owed the Hutt family
a bunch of money after a rough day at
the speeder racing track more on that
later but I'm back I'm a bad doing
the bad batch let's break this bad batch
down in the coming weeks I'll have
time to dedicate an entire video for
each episode but there is so much to get
through that we are breaking episodes
one through seven into two videos this
video have all my favorite moments in
Easter eggs from episode one through
three in my episode four through seven
breakdown will be out next Thursday all
right let's get to it episode 102 are
one story so I'm gonna group them
together twins if you will there is a
dyad episode one The Spoils of War finds
Tech Hunter Echo wrecker and Omega on a
peach-like planet with a Crews getting
attacked by these giant crab-like
creatures here's an Easter egg Omega
bails them out with their bow which I am
hoping isn't that of the night sisters
although people on the internet are
saying it's a zagarian bow and that the
colors they match but the bow structure
is different but please let a boy dream
I want those night sisters sisters
that's a twister reference anyone born
in 96 or later will not get it twisted
sister what is that the bad batch then
heads back to Sid's place where we are
introduced to fee Genoa Sid's pal voiced
by Wanda Sykes there's tons of visual
Easter eggs in here there's a slot
machine in the background with a phase
two stormtrooper helmet az13 is now
running drinks to the regular so kind of
a I guess a simpler job for that Droid
after a really difficult difficult life
on Camino and there are Mandalorian and
clone pilot helmets decorating Sid's
office fees got a nice little mission
for them pick up a bunch of Dooku
droppings more specifically head to the
castle serrano former home of Count
Dooku tales of the Jedi and some
companion novels tell the story that
Dooku left the Jedi Order after his
brother was acting like a real bastard
and he returned to his Homeworld to
become the leader of the separatists and
then he broke bad himself he also
conquered his Homeworld which they left
left out in his glory story accumulating
a massive war chest which is the
droppings I was speaking of that's what
he wants them to steal the war chest
well on route to Serrano Omega overhears
Echo complaining about how the team has
to remain in constant hiding to protect
her at the expense of living their own
lives Bad Bad season one had Omega in
constant need of rescue but in season
two this year is more than capable of
Defending herself the bad batch gets to
Serrano and finds the Empire hauling
away Dooku's Fortune Echo Tech and Omega
sneak onto a giant cargo ship where they
quickly encounter some Stormtroopers and
try to escape by releasing a shipping
container full of the titular Spoils of
War on to episode 2 the ruins of War we
find Echo Tech and Omega hurtling
towards Serrano in a container before
being saved by thrusters thrusters that
Echo taught Omega about earlier in the
episode one and then they land on a
Cliff's Edge teetering for dear life
just like me every day Hunter and
wrecker are trying to escape Dooku's
Palace and get a cool shot at Dooku's
Throne it has that two-prong design that
we see in Darth Vader's Palace and
Mustafar and in the grand inquisitors
chair in Adobe the two prongs are
theorized to be the two cysts there can
only ever be two basically if you're a
Jedi and you see two prongs you got it
all wrong get out of there Omega an echo
and an injured Tech flee to the force
where they meet Romer a native of
serrano Recker and Hunter discover a
junkyard full of separatist tanks like
the ones we saw in Naboo and The Phantom
Menace and of course a bunch of episodes
of The Clone Wars rather than make the
Tank's drivable record just pulls a
weapon out refers to himself as a great
tank himself and then he most threw the
clone troopers it's interesting to note
that the bad batch almost always have
their weapons set to stun so they don't
kill their clone Brothers they still see
them all as family even though they
themselves are their own isolated group
the bad patch finally reunites and Tech
takes down an LA a t gunship with a
Gatling gun on one of the Republic
Speeders Omega has become obsessed with
finishing the mission as she sees the
war chest as a way for the bad batch to
get their freedom and maybe lessen her
burden on the bad batch moving forward
Echo has to save her from dying in a
container and the crew narrowly escaped
Serrano the two-parter concluses with
General rampire ordering Captain Wilco
to falsify reports confirming the bad
batch is in fact dead Wilco says I can't
do that Rampart says I can and then he
blasts him in the back and he takes a
long walk off a short Imperial base wall
quite literally uh the worst severance
package I've ever seen in my life taking
care of yourself is important but we're
not all Geniuses and Poets some of us
review the bad batch for a living it's a
good thing geology makes it easy to do
huh look at this geology is a 16 time
award-winning personalized skin care
company recognized in hypebeast birdie
Men's Health Esquire and ask men
grooming Awards and boasts over 6 000 5
Star reviews just take a 30 second
diagnostic quiz and geology will create
a simple and effective skin care or hair
care routine customized just for you
with ingredients that our dermatologist
tested proven to work and personalized
to your needs for Hair Care geology's
got strengthening shampoo and
conditioner and co-wash which will
transform your routine and deliver the
best hairier your life it extends the
time between washes and replaces the
need for so many products do you wash
your hair less and you save money more
that's method even I understand they
also offer body washes and deodorants
that are free of harsh ingredients and
smell
great for skin care they have you
covered from all angles fight acne
reduce oiliness prevent wrinkles combat
darker puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
their daily personalized skin care
routine comes with two face washes
morning face cream retinol night cream
and eye cream that's 24 hours of creams
baby and right now for a limited time
you get your five piece trial set for
only 15 if you use the code rockstar70
at checkout that's our 150 dollars a
product for just 15 bucks and on top of
that you'll get an additional bonus
offer on one of their brand new skin
hair and body products of your choice
when you add it to your trial to get
started just click the link in the
description let's make those faces
beautiful baby on to episode three the
solitary Cloud this has us shifting over
to the baddest of the bad batch
Crosshair in addition to being the only
Trooper ever to be able to shoot with
any accuracy he's also got the most fun
voice in my opinion I'm a soldier of the
Empire
you've got a voice like this I don't I'm
not doing it right but you know what I
mean he's also doing dealing with being
left on a platform for 30 days all by
himself Crosshair is sent with Commander
Cody hello there to the planet desex to
negotiate the release of Governor Groton
and his conscripted TK Troopers that's
right they're moving in the Troopers
that are no longer clones these are
volunteers non-clone Troopers for those
of you who had girlfriends in high
school or boyfriends for any significant
other me I just had my DND group and my
dolls however Crosshair has been told
secretly he must kill groton's captor
Governor Ames and her battle droid army
Crosshair and Cody stormed the Citadel
of desex and during their standoff with
Governor Ames Ames references her
colleague Nina vanderi and their failed
treaty between the Republic and
separatists seen in an episode of Clone
Wars where they negotiated with Padme oh
Padme Ames and Cody successfully
negotiate the release of Governor Groton
who of course immediately orders Cody to
kill Ames Cody is confused and
conflicted Crosshair says oh wait boy I
got you big bang and blast Ames allowing
the Empire to pillage desex and also
allowing Cody to realize that the empire
tires just kind of a bunch of jerks Cody
and Crosshair meet at the wall of the
phone and Cody says we make our own
decisions and we have to live with them
too before walking away Crosshair thinks
he's just going to get dinner but no no
the next day across here gets his next
mission and finds out Cody has deserted
now if you like desserts for your
deserters and if you like your dessert
in the form of delicious t-shirts I
recommend going to
newrockstarsmerch.com where we have our
Ant-Man collection out right now
including this tasty little number that
was actually recommended and designed by
our own Mt the Vitruvian man and Kang
how much cooler is that you go to new
rockstarsmerch.com we've got Ant-Man and
the WASP Connor Mania shirts now that
you can order and will arrive before the
premiere of the movie dress like me
dress like Jess dress like Eric and the
rest where the new rock stars merch at
the movie if we see each other you might
see me do something like this so head
over to new rockstarsmerch.com to pick
up all of our great Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania shirts as well as we will be
having a Mandalorian show coming out you
know that and you know I'll be wearing
it in all sizes because your boy's
weight is fluctuating like a flux
capacitator that's all for me next week
we'll be breaking down episodes four
through seven and after that we'll have
a dedicated video for each episode
follow me at Tommy bech told follow new
rock stars on all platforms don't forget
to like And subscribe and for now I have
spoken
[Music]